[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec arthur paris ce porte
parole du parti reconquête bonsoir
affaires pas risquer d'être avec nous en
direct
aymeric selmon ce conseiller régional et
rennes en bretagne enfin alexis poulain
éditorialistes arte france bonsoir
également à tous les deux alors avant de
vous faire réagir un messieurs je
voudrais qu'on jette un coup d'oeil sur
les différentes propositions des
candidats sur la question des salaires
et du pouvoir d'achat regardez jean luc
mélenchon christiane taubira augmenter
le smic un 1400 euros net par mois
analyse anne hidalgo augmentation de 15%
soit 200 m par mois fabien roussel et
yannick jadot smic à 1500 euros nets
eric zemmour arthur paris chez vous ou à
votre candidat 13è mois aux salariés
touchant le smic arnaud montebourg
nicolas dupont aignan augmenter le smic
au minimum de 10 % et enfin valérie
pécresse augmenté de 10% les salaires
sur cinq en sachant qu'il ya eu des
petits rétropédalage sur les modalités
pour valérie pécresse
et aymeric seulement aux arènes vous
axez vos mesures du pouvoir d'achat
principalement autour de la baisse des
taxes sur le carburant à 5,5 mais rien
sur les salaires que répondez vous à
tous ces gens dans la rue aujourd'hui
et bien c'est que vous avez mal lu les
propositions de marine le pen car il y à
une proposition très fort sur les
salaires c'est de permettre aux
employeurs d'augmenter de 10% les
salaires jusqu'à 3 fois le smic et la
part qu'ils augmenteront de salaire ne
sera pas soumise aux charges patronales
donc c'est une mesure très forte qui
permettra de redonner du pouvoir d'achat
en plus effectivement des mesures
concrètes sur le les dépenses
quotidiennes des français passent comme
vous l'avez bien souligné le salaire
n'est malheureusement qu'une dès qu'un
des éléments qui permet aux français de
vivre correctement si les salaires
augmentent mais que les dépenses sont
toujours considérables ce n'est pas
possible de vivre convenablement et la
baisse comme vous l'avez indiqué de 20%
à 5 5 sur la tva sur l'ensemble des
produits énergétiques permettra vraiment
de né un bol d'air à l'ensemble des
français alors on reproche à eric
zemmour souvent également la faiblesse
devais me dira peut-être que j'aie mal
lu le programme mais enfin c'est vrai
que c'est quand même le reproche qui
revient souvent
sur parmi les commentateurs ce n'est pas
vraiment le coeur de votre programme
souvent vous dit-on le pouvoir d'achat
qu'est ce que vous répondez pas
effectivement je réponds quand on a du
mal à comprendre ce reproche j'en veux
pour preuve avec deux symboles forts
eric zemmour qui a été rallié dès le
début par jacqueline moreau et par
benjamin cauchy qui sont deux figures
emblématiques du mouvement des gilets
jaunes et vous vous demandez gilet jaune
qui était lui-même un mouvement qui
portait ces questions de pouvoir d'achat
et de pressions sur les salaires que
subissent les français donc déjà je vous
réponds une première partie par ce
ralliement symbolique de deux figures du
pouvoir d'achat dans la campagne dans
l'organigramme proche du candidat
rigoureux et puis je crois que ça fait
quand même déjà plusieurs semaines et
maintenant plusieurs mois qui arrivent
zemmour continue et de montrer ses
propositions sur bon nombre de sujets
procès mais en tout cas c'est un procès
qui correspond pas la réaliser disons
que là vous l'avez énumérer tout à
l'heure sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat a quelque chose de très concret
le treizième mois c'est une baisse de la
csg de 20 points à 5.5 pour tous les
salariés gagnant un salaire jusqu'à 2000
euros net par mois ça concerne 50 % des
salariés français et ça c'est une
augmentation directe c'est un 13e mois
de salaire donc c'est une augmentation à
effet immédiat qui a eu un impact direct
sur la capacité et sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français voilà une réponse
concrète d'eric zemmour il y en a
beaucoup d'autres que je pourrais
énumérer mais en voici une force
symbolique alors on va regarder un
premier message télégramme qui nous
vient à l'instant c'est bon il vaut
mieux diminuer les coûts taxes charges
et cetera qu'augmenter les salaires
alexis poulain
c'est vrai que pour caricaturer un petit
peu c'est la gauche qui met le paquet en
tout cas sur l'augmentation nette des
salaires et la droite pour résumer
également
guerman préfère jouer sur les mécanismes
de baisse de cotisations et de charges
c'est clairement de deux écoles très
différentes le problème de l'école de la
baisse des charges et des cotisations
c'est que c'est une augmentation factice
des salaires puisque ces baisses des
charges c'est moins de services publics
c'est moins de commun et in fine et
c'est des mutuelles qui vont coûter plus
cher c'est c'est finalement des services
publics qui vont coûter plus cher aussi
il faudra trouver des financements donc
et de l'autre côté les caisses de l'état
qui sont déjà massivement endettés
depuis cette crise du coc vie d'un le
gouvernement des macros n'a fait que
creuser la dette pendant ces deux
dernières années trouver les moyens
d'augmenter alors c'est bien sûr la fin
du gel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
et puis on ne peut pas décréter de
l'état ne peut pas demander aux
employeurs d'augmenter unilatéralement
tous les salaires d'une façon
obligatoire donc à part le smic c'est là
la seule finalement le salaire minimum
qui est le seul moyen de jouer sur les
salaires les plus bas et puis après il
ya toutes les aides aussi dans le camp
de gauche sur les plus jeunes soient
revalorisation du rsa mais aussi des
primes pour les jeunes étudiants c'est
dans le programme de jean luc mélenchon
est ailleurs donc on voit bien que ce
sujet du pouvoir d'achat il est arrivé
finalement assez tard
dans la campagne personne ne l'attendait
avec l'inflation qui est un vrai sujet
avec l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
du prix de l'énergie et les candidats
sont en train de se rendre compte que
c'est un thème bien plus important
finalement que la sécurité ou les autres
thèmes qui étaient déjà sur les rails or
aujourd'hui aucun candidat ne se
positionne comme le candidat du pouvoir
d'achat chacun a quelques mesures essai
de bricoler sans avoir finalement de la
solution et je suis assez d'accord avec
le programme du rassemblement national
de dire il faut non seulement jouer sur
les salaires mais jouer sur le coût de
la vie et ça c'est extrêmement important
donc voir comment baisser toutes les
charges tous les coûts induits les le
logement qui est un des postes de
dépenses les plus importantes pour les
ménages aucun candidat aujourd'hui on a
une réflexion poussée sur le logement
horse et c'est ce qui fait que beaucoup
de gens ont du mal à joindre les deux
bouts soit parce qu'ils ont un prêt pour
payer leur logement soit parce qu'ils
sont locataires et que là aussi les prix
ont explosé donc il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire encore et les mesures
comme vous venez de le dire sont
aujourd'hui de 2 écoles baisser les
charges d'un côté augmenter les salaires
minimums de l'autre avec la difficulté
de mettre tout ça en place de manière
assez rapide après l'élection alors de
quoi on parle le salaire médian net en
france il est de 1900 vous savez
d'ailleurs arthur je vous ai dit un
petit peu en dessous de 1,6 en dessous
de 2000 euros dont vous avez 1850 mai
1940 euros nets en france selon l'insee
r je vous propose maintenant de devoir
le salaire médian l'échelle de l'europe
où se situe la france oui c'est pas
extrêmement brillants elle est en queue
de peloton
15,30 euros bruts par heure c'est après
je vais d'ailleurs pas tous les citer
vaut mieux cité par l'arrière ça ira
plus vite un cc juste avant dernier
avant l'italie donc très mauvais
classement pour pour la france des
revendications sont sont parfaitement
légitimes connement on explique sa
selon-vous aymeric seulement
voudrais d'abord réagir à ce que dit
monsieur poulin parce que il ya deux
points qu'il est il a souligné qu'ils me
paraissent intéressants il a dit que le
rôle de l'état n'était pas obligé les
salles les employeurs à augmenter les
salaires mais justement la mesure de
marine le pen est incitative c'est le
rôle de l'état n'est effectivement pas
d'imposer une hausse des salaires dans
les entreprises mais d'inciter des
patrons à le faire et là là
l'exonération des charges sur les
augmentations jusqu'à 3 fois le smic de
10% est une belle incitation et deuxième
point il a indiqué qu' aucun candidat
n'avait de proposition sur le logement
justement marine le pen a fait une
proposition de mettre à disposition de
tous les couples de moins de 30 ans un
prêt gratuit de l'état qui permettrait
justement d'accéder à la propriété à un
coût réduit aujourd'hui donc on voit
bien que l'ensemble des mesures de
marine le pen veut pour le pouvoir
d'achat que ce soit pour les jeunes pour
les salariés pour le même pour les
personnes âgées parce qu'elle vient de
présenter un programme complet et
quelques jours pour les personnes âgées
et le le le pouvoir d'achat est au coeur
du programme de marine le pen je viens
même réponse et pardonnez moi ce que
vous avez pas répondu à la question tout
à l'heure et demie seulement de nature à
rehausser la france dans dans ce tableau
que je viens de vous citer qu on va
peut-être revoir la france vraiment
mauvais élèves sur salaire médian en
europe votre tableau ne parler que du
critère du salaire donc six étapes au
foot un peu faussé parce qu'il faut
pouvoir le comparer avec les taxes que
chaque pays comparé alors je pense que
malheureusement en ajoutant les taxes ça
serait encore plus grave parce qu'on
voit que les taxes en france sont
souvent très importantes mais baisser
les taxes sur le carburant baisser la la
tva à 5,5 en indiquant que les produits
énergétiques sont des produits de
première nécessité ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui ce show créé conduire sa
voiture
un produit de première nécessité donc
c'est le package complet qu'il faut
revoir et augmenter le salaire mais sans
forcément tricher aux pics parce que
monter le spic c'est à dire mettre tout
le monde au split qu'au final n'est pas
la bonne solution ce qu'il faut c'est
permettre aux entreprises de 2
d'augmenter les salaires est je pense un
domaine par exemple éducation où nous
avons des propositions pour vraiment
aider les débutants les jeunes
professeurs parce que là
grave erreur qui sont souvent dans des
zones difficiles il faut revoir non
seulement lundi ce mail échelons qui
permettrait ou au professeur d'avoir des
salaires de meilleur niveau en début de
carrière sur paris c'est vrai comme
aymeric seulement le disait il faut voir
les coups alors en france on a coutume
de le dire et on le sait le coût du
travail et eicher un 37,40 euros par
heure parmi les coulées les plus chères
avec le danemark le luxembourg et
l'allemagne pourtant l'allemagne
envisage un gouvernement de coalition
d'augmenter le smic de plus de 25% ça va
vous paraître une aberration dans votre
partie reconquête nom alors je pense que
vous venez de dire c'est que aujourd'hui
on a une problématique entre sur la
question du coût du travail on a un smic
ou en tout cas un salaire de toute façon
un salaire brut qui est important qui
est trop fort pour l'employeur et un
salaire net qui est trop faible pour le
salarié c'est pour ça que la proposition
d'eric zemmour fait sens sur la question
de la baisse de la csg elle permet de
répondre à ces deux problématiques qui
essaie justement de baisser le coût pour
la charge de l'employeur et d'augmenter
la rémunération à la charge du salarié
donc là c'est quelque chose de concret
où on allait encore une fois la
compétitivité de l'entreprise avec les
intérêts du salarié maintenant je trouve
que ce qui est intéressant pour mettre
en perspective ce qui était dit plus tôt
par messieurs c'est que il faut avoir
une politique de vision globale on
pourrait comparer les mesures pendant 10
15 20 minutes ce qui est important et
c'est ce que dira exercé que le constat
qui fait depuis 40 ans et que la france
a été massivement désindustrialisé le
taux de l'industrie aujourd'hui en
france il est passé de 13% quand les
concurrents italiens anglais et
allemands sont restés à plus de 20% on a
une baisse en gros 2 on est passé en
dessous de la barre des 20 % à 13 % en
30 ans cette désindustrialisation à la
cua comme effet des délocalisations donc
des fermetures d'entreprises des
fermetures d usines donc des gens qui se
retrouvent au chômage
nécessairement que je vous retrouve au
chômage vous avez une baisse de votre
pouvoir d'achat ce que vous avez une
baisse des salaires c'est un cercle
vicieux baisse de la compétitivité et
c'est le serpent qui se mord la queue
donc sous cette qui sont là il faut
avoir une vision d'ensemble il faut
réindustrialiser la france et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'eric zemmour fait des
propositions fortes avec un grand
mystère d'industrie pour avoir une
vision globale sur les trente prochaines
années moi ce qui m'inquiète notamment
sur la question du front national quand
du rassemblement national quand je les
écoute c'est qu'il propose beaucoup
pour distribuer de l'argent donc on ne
sait pas vraiment d'où il vient donc il
ya beaucoup de propositions pour pour
pour alimenter pour donner il y en a
beaucoup moins pour financer et l'autre
problématique c'est que venant d'un
parti qui a environ 20 millions de
dettes sur les cinq dernières années je
crois je crois que quand on a vocation à
gouverner le pays il faudra aussi en
capacité de gérer son parti je crois que
sur cette question là on peut aussi se
poser la question la gestion du budget
et la gestion d'un budget national dans
les contraintes aujourd'hui connaît la
france c'est à dire dans des enjeux
européen et mondial alexis bout là on va
on va revoir un je faisais allusion
cette hausse des salaires en europe pour
l'année 2022 l'allemagne qui fait fort
qui envisage de plus de 25% sur le smic
notamment au royaume uni + 7 % espagne +
3 6 % comment ces pays arrive à financer
une telle hausse et pourquoi la france
est à la traîne et le ministre de
l'économie d'ailleurs continuer à nous
dire barre la une augmentation de
salaire ça sera un frein à la
compétitivité finalement
il faut il faut savoir que le salaire
minimum est un des plus élevés en france
donc là on a des pays qui font du
rattrapage qui sont très loin derrière
par rapport à notre smic donc la réalité
c'est que la france est toujours assez
très loin sur la le le salaire minimum
donc c'est juste du rattrapage ces pays
peuvent le faire parce que ils ont une
économie qui fonctionne
avec la balance du commerce extérieur et
autres nous on n'a pas finalement de
hausse parce que on est déjà bien lotis
en termes de salaire minimum donc c'est
mécanique il ya la question bien sûr du
salaire minimum européen qui revient
assez souvent qu'on n'a pas encore
tranché parce qu'il ya de telles
disparités au sein de l'union européenne
qu'on ne peut pas avoir un salaire qui
serait le même pour tous ça n'aurait
aucun sens même si on a une monnaie
l'euro 1 qui est la même pour tous et
qui a posé quelques problèmes
rappelons-nous la crise grecque donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
la france n'a pas à aujourd'hui à rougir
de ce salaire minimum au contraire et
que les autres partenaires européens
essayent de se mettre à niveau parce
qu'ils sont loin derrière compte tenu de
ce qui est nous le nôtre est minime
avant de passer la parole à aymeric
seulement je voudrais vous faire lire ce
nouveau message télégrammes nicolas
augmenter les salaires ça ne sert à rien
mois plus tard tout augmentera car les
grosses boîtes voudront leur part c'est
une critique qui revient assez souvent
dans notre pays également ça vous
inspire quoi aymeric salma
c'est le rôle de l'état de contrôler
l'inflation et ça c'est effectivement il
faut avoir des mesures fortes parce
qu'une petite inflation est utile pour
que la la société fonctionne
correctement une grosse inflation
effectivement si les salaires augmentent
et que le coût de la vie augmente en
parallèle l'augmentation salariale
n'aura servi à rien
certes mais c'est pour ça que les
mesures parions sur les carburants sont
importantes alors juste répondre à
monsieur pâris quand même qui me attaque
un peu bassement sur les finances du
rassemblement national
oui un parti politique qui participent
aux élections en france a besoin
d'emprunter pour financer ses candidats
et c'est tout à son honneur et vous
verrez que peut-être que dans quelques
années quand votre parti aura plusieurs
années d'existence si le renard et s'il
présente des candidats dans des
élections locales il aura probablement
aussi des dettes à régler pour financer
les différentes campagnes électorales et
notre parti de malheureusement n'a pas
de gros financiers comme monsieur
bolloré derrière lui ça fait peut-être
la différence et voilà ce que je voulais
dire à monsieur pâris et pour revenir
donc au au cours de la vie parce que je
pense par exemple que la mesure de ce
zemmour de faire payer aux entreprises
la moitié des consommations de carburant
des employés va être un gros coup sur la
tête désormais ans devant et je commence
je me demande bien comment les
employeurs pourront financer cette
mesure et je pense que pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français il vaut
mieux baisser les taxes que faire payer
cette augmentation continuelle
malheureuse du carburant tard par les
employeurs
bah ça ça m'évoque malheureusement toute
la fibre gauchistes de marine le pen
puisque toute façon aujourd'hui il est
assez difficile pour un observateur
d'être en capacité différencier le
peut-être 30 capacité de différencier le
programme économique de jean luc
mélenchon en génie dolgo avec celui de
marine le pen soit sur la question de la
retraite ou sur la question de tout
financer tout le temps par des par des
baisses de charges je choisis aussi sur
la question effectivement de la prise en
charge de 50 % des frais de carburant
pour les salariés par les entreprises ça
c'est comme une mesure assez symbolique
ce que tous les français dans les
territoires qui sont obligés de prendre
leur voiture pour aller au dos sur les
trajets domicile travail ils sont cette
contrainte là c'est que déjà en plus
cette aide par les entreprises dans les
grandes villes parce qu'elles prennent
en charge des transports en commun donc
je pense que celle ci est nécessaire et
je rebondis aussi je reproduis juste un
point un peu technique un point après
monsieur juste un point technique sur la
question du poids sur les entreprises je
vous crois que n'êtes pas sans ignorer
que c'est déductible des charges donc de
toute façon les entreprises qui mettront
cette part du carburant pour les
salariés qui la prendront en charge pour
qui la prendront en charge pour
justement la déduire de leurs charges
donc l'argument comme quoi est un coût
pour les entreprises c'est un argument
faux il suffit de discuter quand on
prend les ans pour les entrepreneurs
pour qu'ils vous explique que cet
argument ne tient pas donc c'est pour ça
que encore une fois il faut pas tomber
dans l'idéologie politique il faut pas
non plus tomber dans la facilité la
facilité qui est dit en distribuer des
chèques de 1000 euros 10000 euros
cinquante mille euros ils sont
déconnectés derrière d'un financement de
l'opération
non mais je fais allusion personne ne
l'a vraiment je ne vise personne mais
c'était le cas notamment sur les
candidats de gauche on l'entend depuis
le début il envoie la planche à billets
il en voit l'hélicoptère à monet mais
derrière comment est ce que vous faites
en ce moment c'est pas les seuls mais
c'est pour ça que je dis que ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir des mesures
compétitif des mesures immédiates à
effet immédiat que les français pourront
percevoir tout de suite après l'élection
d'eric zemmour parce que elles auront un
impact un impact immédiat mais il faut
aussi avoir une vision sur les vingt
trente quarante cinquante prochaines
années à venir sur les questions
d'industrie l'industrie nucléaire la
métallurgie la syrie temps vous me doper
pas les investissements de ces secteurs
là vous vous retrouvez toujours avec la
même problématique
avant de clore ce débat je voudrais
qu'on s'intéresse à ce qui se passe aux
etats unis parce que ça interpelle le
mouvement s'appelle la grande
résignation regarder the greek risible
et shon 4,5 millions d'américains ont
quitté leur emploi en novembre dernier
pourquoi un ras-le-bol et la quête de
sens à leur travail c'était après le
confinement revalorisation des salaires
c'est là que ça nous intéresse de
certaines grandes ancien salaire minimum
de 15 dollars contre 12 ou 10 et au
dernier trimestre le niveau des bas
salaires augmenter de 2 6% l ex poulain
ce qui se passe aux etats unis c'est un
finalement 1 1
du rapport de force à ce qu'on peut
imaginer la même chose en france où on
est loin du compte pour le moment on est
loin du compte et il faut voir que le
marché du travail américain est beaucoup
plus fluide on peut trouver de l'emploi
plus facilement par ce qui fait que il
ya ce moment de grande des missions
plutôt que résignation parce que
derrière on peut aller effectivement
trouver un emploi et qu'on a beaucoup de
petits jobs c'est l'économie du job
certains qui ont plusieurs travail pour
pouvoir nourrir leurs familles ce qui ce
qui n'est pas le cas en france puisqu'on
a cdi cdd enfin tout est encadré a droit
du travail particulier même s'il ya eu
la loi travail évidemment poussé par
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il était ministre
mais on est on est loin de ce fait là ce
qui se passe en revanche c'est que il ya
eu les confinements il ya eu la crise
ducobu qui est passée par là il ya eu
une perte de sens il une réflexion si
sûr bah finalement c'est quoi la vie et
est ce que je est-ce que ça vaut le coup
de travail et pour quelques dollars où
est ce que je ferais pas mieux
m'organiser autrement trouver autre
chose et c'est sûr qu'il ya un mouvement
de de repli à la fois sur la sphère
personnelle mais aussi de moins
d'engagement au sein de la sphère
professionnelle pour ces petits jobs
notamment en dix ans ensea ça ne vaut
rien finalement ça ne sert à rien et là
je pense qu'on peut aussi retrouver un
écho peut-être en france quand on voit
notamment chez les jeunes à une
démission ou le manque d envie de
s'engager au sein de grandes boîtes du
cac 40 par exemple de chercher des
métiers qui font sens donc c'est plus
quelque chose de mondial on va dire qui
a été accéléré je pense par la crise du
comité qui est du domaine de la
recherche de sens mais ça dépend
vraiment là encore de la structure du
marché du travail en france c'est très
loin c'est pas du tout comparable au
marché du travail américain merci alexis
poulain en proposera votre chat de
participer au débat parce que je crois
qu'il faut être
sexy annonce jean tactique on
l'entendait miauler et on espère qu'il
s'est pas fait mal quand vous l'avez
chassés de 2 devant la caméra
merci également aymeric seulement et
arthur paris c'est avoir été avec nous
pour ce débat merci